So there’s a methodology called k-Nearest
Neighbor in big data analysis where you can
find a person who looks similar to another
person.
Who’s the most similar on a number of traits?
But I kind of renamed the search a doppelganger
search because I think that’s a cooler name
for it and also accurate.
So you basically look in a huge data set,
you take a person and say “Who is the person
who looks most similar to that person?”
So one way you might use this is if Amazon’s
looking for what books to recommend.
They may find your book-reading doppelganger.
So across the whole universe of Amazon customers,
who’s the person who tends to buy books
like you have bought?
And then what books has that person recently
read and enjoyed that you haven’t read and
enjoyed?
And that’s sort of how they recommend books
to you.
And this can be used in a lot of other areas.
People are just starting to use this in health
where you can say, across the entire universe
of patients who has symptoms very similar
to your symptoms, and what has worked for
those people, are your health doppelgangers.
So it’s a very powerful methodology and
it gets more powerful the more data you have.
Because the more data you have the more similar,
the more likely you’re going to find someone
in that data set who’s really, really similar
to you.
Some of this stuff, some of the big data analysis
are things we have always kind of done.
That’s kind of what doctors try to do.
They try to say, “Who are you similar to?
Of all the patients I’ve seen, which ones
remind me of your case, and what worked for
them?”
But they’ve been doing this on a small number
of patients, namely the ones they’ve seen.
Whereas the potential for big data is you
can do it over the entire universe of patients
and get people who are, really, much, much
more similar to you.
Really zoom in on the tiny subset of people
who have a very similar path to you.
Instead of saying “You have the condition
depression” which might remind a doctor
of a hundred depressed patients that he’s
seen over the past couple of years, you can
say maybe that “You have a particular type
of depression.”
So you maybe sleep all the time whereas other
depressed patients don’t sleep all the time,
and you feel guilty whereas other depressed
patients don’t feel guilty, and then really
find these people who are really, really similar
who’s depression has taken a much more similar
path to yours than have other people’s depressions.